thank you
[Applause]
32.
32 I like how he smiled when he said
that y'all gonna have to break that [__]
up we're good we're gonna break that up
in front of me bro all right I got you I
got girl I got you
whatever you need to be going you're a
little girl oh
[__] she's my daughter try to protect
that [__] she's my daughter hey hey I
don't know when Alabama family you got
going on but you a little bit too close
to your daughter okay
he was I don't know what prawn said
y'all just left but he was he was he's
so close he was almost in her
that was disgusting
also
hey
what kind of dad someone asked yo what's
going on here with this girl and just
starts divulging information about her
age and everything a dad would be
protective of his daughter who the [__]
are you bro
bro we do not you don't even need to
explain yeah the capituation Hey listen
of that lie that reaction was not a yes
that was not that yeah who the [__] is
you
you know what's even weird about all
this this happening on a pride festival
I think it has nothing to do with pride
let's let's not put pride in there no
the reason why I'm saying it's weird
that it's happening at pride is that you
have all of these people right you have
all this gay lesbian stuff going on and
then you have this 32 year old hovering
over she didn't even look 16 to be
honest with you know she looked like she
could be 12 13. yeah
yeah so it's just like you got all of
this happening all around it nobody's
even noticing how much yes that this
grown ass man is hovering this clothes
like mouth to mouth with a 13 year old
in in front of other people
you don't do that [__] y'all break that
[__] up right now I'm gonna have to
leave his coach
huh
my wife's my wife your wife wait where
your wife back go get her okay she's
taking it out there go get her I got you
yeah
nothing wrong at all man yeah some gotta
be wrong man I got you man oh you 37
years old she's 16. listen to how you
sound listen to how you sound this is my
daughter
too much bro okay I got it listen how
you sound man I got you man yeah y'all
gotta break that up right now
[Music]
you don't have to explain how cap that
is you don't okay I only wish I could
see how this [__] ended yes no I was
done I mean everything is off about that
[__] and you call the police on that
[__] yeah let's break that off we're
just gonna go somewhere else grabs her
by the hand nah bee
everybody's catching a charge and mind
you they was hanging out like right in
front of a bar hovering over it like
they talking with the patrons inside
there's so many things wrong with this
thing I don't know how to
I don't know when EDP is going on right
now
he really tried I wish I could have seen
how that [__] ended that's my only
regret I'm definitely gonna make that
dude's face a thumbnail I'm just saying
this
that is disgusting
that's disgusting the truth is there's a
lot of these older dudes trying to groom
these young ladies I'm not sure the
opposite happens we see the stories now
coming out with the school teachers
same thing it's the same thing okay
we're not gonna talk about the dudes
these old ass [__] are doing
that it's man it's women yeah but let's
be honest with let's be honest
it happens more with Matt let's be
honest you're not suspect for a lot of
these dudes when they go after these
girls these days just because they're so
malleable easily like just you can tell
them what to do and they look at you and
they fear you ah whenever I see dudes
going this crazy for women that are that
young I always think they're a bit of a
loser and that they're just trying to go
for a woman who are going to look up to
them like they even though they haven't
really earned any news like look at this
dude like the moment he gets confronted
look how scared he looked how wimpy he
became he knows he knows you know the
thing is I remember when I was a kid
like all these girls all these girls
were
they were fangirling over these these
men that were older than them Brad Pitt
Jason priceley
uh a bunch of people everybody a whole
cast of Beverly Hills 9020 the first
edition or like they were they were
ending people were in high school they
were five fingerling so the girls
actually
girls go for that too let's be clear
girls really like that the older man
you're the grown-up as a man that you
are the girl wants that you're the
grown-up though
that's not what's gonna happen and stuff
like that you're the one that has the
moral in your head you're 32. you're in
your 30s
these kids get it they see these things
on TV and they idolize it get it concur
I understand what you're saying loud and
clear here that happened and they might
want to idolize that you are the
grown-up
men or woman
so
to be clear though most of the events is
that older people make on young people
are not reciprocated
yeah I went walking down the street and
these old geezers are coming onto them
that's not because women idolize Brad
Pitt it's just because these dudes a
[__] and they can be saying no
absolutely just like the other video
where the girl was like I'm 17. so
what's your point yeah yeah absolutely
so it's not even so much I understand
yeah but I already hear the people like
talking about that that's pretty for
even for that particular thing you're
the grown-up
you are the one with the moral compass
compass compass there's ass in there
it's a compass it's Compass thank you
you're the one with more compass
you're the one that's supposed to think
straight
you're the one with experience like why
am I oh there's a lot of this stuff we
have like dozens of videos that were
sent into us about who's doing this kind
of weird [__] I just I don't know I
don't know what would you do actually no
here's the next question I ask you okay
what'd you do if you know somebody like
this in your life friend or family oh no
I'm stepping in
what you mean like I know you found out
that they've been doing that stuff what
do you mean you're gonna step in would
they've been doing that stuff yeah
we're gonna have to have a talk yeah I'm
the guy that have talk with my people
when I see some [__] is weird I don't
want to understand some [__] what the
hell going on here like you know I have
Old Uncle Bob
why
can you explain to me what the [__] is
going on here like I gotta understand
what's going on if I really really read
it right I'm not gonna go off what other
people say I'm gonna see like yeah what
what it what it what's your sign
I have a conversation with the the dude
definitely
and see where is that at and then from
that I'm gonna decide if I discarded or
not I'm not gonna try to stay around
because then again the thing that
happened is that if I let it slide then
I'm involved
and people are going to link oh yeah
that dude that you know they don't link
me to that that's not me
that's you
I don't do what no
if it's me you gotta go
what are you doing ain't no
conversations I'm not going to try to
understand
if you do anything with kids you gotta
go you're gonna say you go yeah you got
to go you're gonna go are you doing that
yeah then you gotta go
if you've already offended if you tell
me you have thoughts you tell me you
doing stuff
you gotta go
you you Skip and go you're going
straight to jail
no two handles no no that's just no I
don't I don't
I don't feel it's the same thing if it's
like a 20 year old with a 17 year old
I'm not a [__] okay 21 year old like
I'm not stupid 32 with 16. but you and
your 25s talking to 16 15 year olds uh
you gotta go
I don't care what nobody says that's a
no for me if you want to be condone to
that kind of stuff that's fine I mean I
see grown ass man just like idolizing
and going after these young women just
I said no even the other way around
that's enough
so those are my thoughts on this
I was just imagining the situation and
what I would do and everything
everything in my body was just you gotta
go that was all I could think I mean I
want kids like I can't hear you in my
life
you know what I mean I got these like I
can't have you in my life
I can't be looking on the shoulder being
like is this your next one like just
know
I don't have to calculate anything with
the people around me yeah my kids going
to be there I can't really leave my kids
I'm not doing those mathematics I'm not
doing Predator method mathematics okay
I'm not doing that I'm not doing that
that's enough I'm not doing that that's
a thud we're not doing that that's it I
just wanted to say that let us know what
you guys think in the comments below but
yeah